لكن بكين تعد لهم الجيوش بين
مناطيد وروبوتات وغيرها الكثير.
المصحف بعد استدعاء سفيرها في
تركيا منجم ايقاد للذهب في صحراء
المنطقة وهو كنز جديد قد يوفر
مليارات الدولارات للمصريين.
احتجاجات تخرج اسبوعيا وطيار
اسرائيلي يهدد علنا اغتيال رئيس
الحكومة الجزائرية لمضاعفة زراعة
القمح بهدف الوصول للاكتفاء
يجرم الاتجار بالبشر بعقوبة قد
تصل للمؤبد بينما تستمر جهود
الذاتي وتجنب اثار ازمة الغذاء
العالمية. ان تمنع احراق نسخة من
تعني تخلي امريكان عن النفط
السوري وهو ما تحسب له واشنطن
للتعامل مع الجماعات الكردية.
يرغب اردوغان بهذه الاليات قبل
الحرب في سوريا ما قد يغير خارطة
الصراع بشكل كبير فيما قد تكون
طرفا اساسيا في الصراع في سوريا.
دمشق تريد انسحابا جزئيا او كليا
من وزنه بثلاثين مرة. ولمواجهة
تلك الجيوش الصينية يتجه
انقرة تتقرب من دمشق. مع اقتراب
المصالحة بين النظام السوري
حيث يقوم هذا الروبوت وهو في
الحالة الصلبة بنقل حمولة اكبر
بسهولة. درب العلماء الصينيون
الروبوت على الحركة ونقل الحمولة
الصيني. وقال مسؤول امريكي ان
الحطام موجود على عمق سبعة
جيشا اخر غير المناطيد. هنا
روبوت صيني يتحول من الحالة
مائة واربعين عنصرا من مجموعة
فاغنر الروسية في بخموت. ليأتي
ليصرح انه اخذ وعدا من الرئيس
الروسي بوتين بعدم قتل نظيره
وسيلة. ومن بين ركام الاخبار ظهر
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق
على باخموت. قالت وزارة الدفاع
البريطانية ان روسيا احرزت تقدما
كانت محط اهتمام القوات الروسية
منذ اسابيع. انهم يقاتلون من
وقال قائد مجموعة فاجنر الروسية
الملقب بطباخ بوتين ان قتالا
هذه المرة يقولها رئيس وزراء
الكيان الاسرائيلي بان اسرائيل
اجل استهداف الاراضي الروسية. من
يتجنبون مواجهة الروس هم كثر لكن
الغربية بعيدة المدى. وبرغم ان
استخبارات كييف كانت قد اعلنت ان
الدولارات والجزائر تظهر معنى
الانسانية. تطبخ حربا كبرى.
مصر الشرقية هو احدث المناجم
التي اكتشفت مؤخرا في تلك
الوزراء نتنياهو قال استمر في
تنفيذ خطة لاصلاح القضاء تصفها
المعارضة بالانقلاب. رسالة موسكو
تصل والدول تعلن تجنب مواجهة
فمن يقوى على مواجه
بعدم المساس بالزلنسكي بينما
تفضح موسكو مسرحية الامريكان
الروسية وانسحابات تدريجية للجيش
الاوكراني من باخموت. وبوتين يعد
الف حساب. الاحداث والتطورات.
الجزائر يصادق على مشروع قانون
لتعزيز الدفاعات في مواجهة الصين
ببحريها الشرقي والجنوبي وفق
للقوات التركية من اراضيها.
بينما تحاول انقرة توفير مناخ
الولايات المتحدة الخاسر الاكبر
بين القوى الدولية وتعد تركيا
امن لبدء عودة اللاجئين السوريين
الى بلادهم والذين يقدر عددهم
حليفا دائما في السلم والحرب.
كما ان مصالحة انقرة ودمشق قد
الاف الاسرائيليين في شوارع تل
ابيب ضد حكومة نتنياهو في اطار
الامريكان لنشر صواريخ متوسطة
المدى باليابان في اطار خطة
خوض الانتخابات القادمة. اما
روسيا فسيكسبها استقرار سوريا
الروس. بينما يتجه نظر واشنطن
لمواجهة الصين مع تجميع الحلفاء
بثلاثة ملايين ونصف المليون لاجئ
فضلا عن تعاون سوريا مع تركيا
واشنطن وبكين والبنتاجون يتهم
الصين بامتلاك اسطول من مناطيد
وتركيا ماذا تريد انقرة من دمشق
وما الذي يريده بشار الاسد من
رسوم جمركية على البضائع
البريطانية. الانتقام الصيني.
التجسس في سماء خمس قارات. قصة
المنطاد لم تنتهي لتبدأ سفن
الصلبة الى الحالة السائلة.
ويتمكن من تحرير نفسه من القضبان
تابعة لخفر السواحل الامريكي
بتأمين منطقة سقوط حطام المنطاد
واربعين قدما ما يسهل عملية جمعه
بحسب شبكة سي ان ان. بكين تبني
تختبئ تحت الرماد. اوى بالون ام
منضاد؟ لا يهم. الاهم ان وزارة
ان بكين تحتفظ بالحق في استخدام
الوسائل اللازمة للتعامل مع
بالقوة رد مبالغ فيه معربة عن
احتجاجها الشديد. واضافت الوزارة
الدفاع الصينية قالت ان اقدام
واشنطن اسقاط المنطاد المدني
تحت رعاية روسية بالاساس. قد
يحصل هذا لاول مرة منذ اندلاع
بالون واحد صب الزيت على نار
التوترات الصينية الامريكية التي
المواقف المماثلة. ازمة اسقاط
المنطاد الصيني تفاقم التوتر بين
اردوجان يطرق اردوغان مجددا
ابواب النظام السوري تقارب معه
ريشيسوناك قوانين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتشمل الاجراءات فرض
الاوروبيون باتخاذ اجراءات ضد
بريطانيا في الغى رئيس وزراء يا
عن غزو العراق الجائر حيث لقد
اصبحت صورة كولومباول وهو يظهر
العقاب في تلك المسرحية المخزية
على ارض بلاد الرافدين. ومن
زخارف هذه المرة بل نائب وزير
الخارجية الروسي رياكوف متحدثا
معارك التصريحات الى حرب
الاتاوات والضرائب. حيث يهدد
صحيفة وتضيف الصحيفة ان ارسال
العتاد للقوات الامريكية في
الاوكرانيسكي. لنعد الى
التعليقات الروسية. ولكن ليست
اليابان قد يشمل اسلحة بعيدة
المدى اسرع من الصوت وصواريخ.
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الغبار
عن جسده ويقول ان التهديدات
بخموت وتخلي بعض المناطق هناك
بسبب نقص الذخيرة والجنود. لينفض
من مدينة باخموت. وبينما تكمل
القوات الروسية طوقها بشكل كامل
الروسية الاخيرة بشن ضربات
انتقامية ضد بلاده هي محاولة
لتركيع الاوكرانيين. مشيرا الى
ان بلاده ستستعيد كل اراضيها باي
الاتصال ايضا يا زينسكي? دعونا
نعود قليلا الى الحرب الاوكرانية
تجسيدا للنفاق وثقة النخبة
الامريكية الحاكمة بافلاتها من
انبوب اختبار به مسحوق يزعم انه
الجمرة الخبيثة منذ فترة طويلة
زيادة التوسع في قدرات الجيش
الاوكراني خلال اتصال هاتفي مع
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريش
سوناك. لكن ماذا ناقشتم خلال
عنيفا مستمرا للاجزاء الشمالية
لمدينة باخموت الاوكرانية والتي
يا اصدقاء حيث لا جديد غير
التقدمات الروسية المتواصلة.
في تطويق دومبس لتعلن وزارة
الدفاع الاوكرانية عن مقتل وجرح
الخبر اليقين من مجلة بوليتكو ان
قوات كييف تنسحب تدريجيا من
شارع لشارع ومنزل لمنزل ضد
القوات الاوكرانية التي لم تنسحب
مضيفا انه تم التوصل لحل الوسط
مع الرئيس الروسي بوتين بحيث لا
لكلا في الاجواء السورية وذلك
بحسب قناة ال سي ايه الفرنسية.
يتم انتهاك العلاقات مع موسكو.
هناك تمد كييف نظرها نحو المملكة
البريطانية ليقول الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي انه بحث كيفية
لا تريد مواجهة مع روسيا ووقوع
حوادث بين الطائرات العسكرية
الدفاع الاوكراني ان بلاده لن
تستهدف الاراضي الروسية بالاسلحة
ليؤكد المستشار الالماني غلاف
شولز عن وجود اتفاق مع زالنسكي
يقضي بعدم استخدام الاسلحة
الغربية المرسلة لاوكرانيا من
موسكو صارت هدفا مشروعا لكن
الغرب لا يغامر بخطوة كهذه.
خططها في سوريا على نار هادئة.
فيما مصر تكتشف كنزا بمليارات
لتكون كييف هي اول من يتجنب
تحذير الدب الروسي باعلان وزير
التهديدات الروسية تتطاير يمنة
ويسرة، لكن لا يلتقطها الجميع
الضيقة يصنعون روبوتا خارقا
للعادة لا يمكن حبسه. تركيا تطبخ
وحرب اخرى تندلع بين الصينيين
والامريكيين واصحاب العيون
هزلية في العراق. بكين لواشنطن
نحتفظ بحق الرد بكافة الوسائل
استهداف الاراضي الروسية. فما
الذي يجري دومباست تعود للمائدة
نريد مواجهة الدب الروسي ليكفينا
حوادث. هكذا خضع الكيان
الاسرائيلي لتهديدات بوتين وكييف
على نهج تل ابيب تتعهد بعدم